[Applause]
i mean i got to know the context i think
you're allowed to curse out your kids
i hate this kid doing this man why can't
you curse out your kids
you can like why is this bad because
it's normal in the black people
frankly that's how he's gonna say kirk
flank he's a black singer he's not his
fan base is not white enough to care
about this
yeah he's got a black fan base they're
gonna hear this and be like i don't give
a [ __ ]
that's a regular phone call yeah yeah
but is he not allowed because he's
religious is that the other
that's the idea that's what it is so
what is he supposed to do what are
religious people supposed to do in that
situation
where their kid does something annoying
where you want to put your foot up their
[ __ ]
yeah i think you just hit him growing up
in the christian south you get whipped
so you're allowed to do that there's no
it doesn't say that you're not allowed
[ __ ] his son
how dare you [ __ ] you how dare you
record
yeah [ __ ] ass [ __ ] i'm just
some [ __ ] i hate that son yo
yeah this is what's happened to alec
baldwin right what happened
he was he was cut oh no was that mel
gibson he was cussing out his daughter
and then uh
and his daughter like exposed him
recorded no that was his wife's yeah
he had his wife he called his like
six-year-old daughter that's a greedy
little pig the whole girl was like
what but now we would do we have a
double standard though although it was
like because
that is hilarious he called his
six-year-old daughter
you're a young greedy little people this
is like early 2000's we're talking about
that 2007 something like that we're
gonna need that video bro i don't
understand why you can't be upset at
your kids right about gibson was not
very defensible but this
yeah this [ __ ] i defend this and i
defend it
you're a greedy little pig yo
yeah maybe but like i just don't
understand why people are up in arms
is it because he's is because he's uh
what's it called proselytizing
all the time is that yes so it's like so
is so
because he's saying he's pushing the
gospel he's supposed to act that way in
his life is that
yeah i suppose like a christian who
walks in i guess
whatever walks in the faith or whatever
the term is you wouldn't cuss
oh so it's just the curse words it's the
curse words it's not about the violence
that's what's funny this is the alec
baldwin phone call and i want to leave a
message for you right now
because again it's 10 30 here in new
york on a wednesday
and once again i've made an ass
of myself trying to get you a phone to
call you at a specific time
when the time comes for me to make the
phone call i
stop whatever i'm doing and i go when i
make that phone call
at 11 o'clock in the morning in new york
and if you don't pick up the phone
at 10 o'clock at night and you don't
even have that goddamn phone turned on
i want you to know something okay i i'm
tired of playing this game with you
i'm leaving this message with you to
tell you you have insulted me
for the last time
[Music]
pain in the ass who doesn't care about
what you do as far as i'm concerned
you have humiliated me for the last time
of this phone
and when i come out there next week i'm
gonna fly out there for the day
just to straighten you out on this issue
i'm gonna let you know just how
disappointed in you i am
and how angry i am with you that you've
done this to me again
you've made me do any of y'all know what
he did
or she did to him she wasn't answering
his calls right
that's it yeah he's that's what he's
saying
i'm tired of you turning your phone off
that's what seems to be it
okay she was 11. yeah but answer your
[ __ ] phone like
i get that frustration sometimes i'll
text mark three times because i need
some [ __ ] he don't pick up his [ __ ]
phone
that's what that message i want to leave
well i'm not a thoughtless little pig
you are a thoughtless little girl
yeah you are oh i'm an awful little pig
no
so here's the thing i don't understand
about this obviously it's bitch-ass of
the kids to expose their parents that's
some [ __ ] [ __ ]
right i'm annoyed about that but being
upset at your kids is so regular
like why are we acting like this is
wrong that's a good point you never had
your parents yell at you
you've been yelled at have you not oh
yeah like badly or not
what's the worst thing your parents ever
did to you oh yeah let's go
i don't remember my dad yelled at me one
time and he used some village hindi that
i swear to god i've never heard him use
again what a satellite means
grab the machete so it makes it real i
don't remember i was just like what the
[ __ ] is he speaking to me right now
i know hindi this is i've never heard
before and i never heard it again
he was [ __ ] livid wow that's it
that's the most i got yelled at but
that's it nothing crazy
nothing crazy what'd you do to deserve
it though right y'all never got yelled
at son
yeah like what was it i mean like i had
my mom probably did crazy my parents had
a whole other person's birthday on my
birthday
once and when i complained about it
yelled at me
wait what the heck some [ __ ]
one of their friends one of my mom's
friends [ __ ] wait was she a kid
whole adult [ __ ] i literally said to
them i'm walking with my dad like i'm
having like a tip about this
i was mad young when birthdays mattered
and i was walking with my dad and i said
i was like yo
it's not weird i remember exactly where
i was ask her astra place in broadway
i was like yo it's not weird that you're
having someone else's birthday on my
birthday
and then my dad was like my dad's the
most like easy going about everything he
goes
i had enough of this we're not talking
about this anymore stop being spoiled
and i'm like
spoiled i can't have my birthday on my
birthday you got some other [ __ ]
mom's friends an old ass [ __ ]
it makes so much sense though
every year comes by he's like i don't
like doing anything for my birthday
that's a good point yeah that's a good
point
i've been scarred and abused i'm sorry
where's chris hanson
but this whole story is about your
parents yelling at you and his dad
called him spoiled
yeah well it's not dad i've
[Applause]
bitch's birthday in my house they were
singing
happy birthday to not me
on my birthday while i sat in my room
watching the spice channel
you don't get enough attention the other
364 days a year yeah
no that's that really is like that's
that is worse than raping your kids
bro
real talk that is terrifying dude
i remember exactly what i was happy
birthday dear katrina
[ __ ] you [ __ ] that's your her that's
your katrina that [ __ ] was my control
yeah
the way that came in and destroyed my
house
let me tell you something george bush
don't care about white people
either let's go he's in a flyover for
your birthday just looking at it oh
that's that's andy's birthday
they didn't even do a happy birthday to
you both oh yeah
they knew i was in the house i was too
young to leave
it was as if they were teasing me they
were taunting me
happy birthday they got louder katrina
and no one else nobody else would
possibly want a bird
like fakes his uh memory loss because
i'll be bringing that [ __ ] up and he'd
be like i don't know what you're talking
about
oh convenience oh now we got alzheimer's
when we got to remember
traumatic times of my childhood yeah you
never turned seven
i'd never do that dramatic this guy
wait a minute does that mean i'm 36 oh
10 years back baby
look at you let's take a year back can
we throw you a seventh birthday
yeah we we should throw the seventh
birthday we're gonna do that we're gonna
do that
done yeah i mean it's unbelievable bro
you're on some harry potter [ __ ] bro i
am on some harry potter [ __ ] and it was
my mom's fault [ __ ]
i don't blame my dad my dad was probably
fighting for me
yeah well my dad was probably out there
like nah we shouldn't do it we shouldn't
celebrate katrina's birthday
my mom was like no let's do it yeah make
your own reality
yeah we're making it yeah all right mom
i know what you're up to
mom try me disrespect your boy
that's why whose birthday got forgotten
this year
yeah i'm saying my mom all upset yep let
me ask you this
scoreboard february 23rd came around not
a single phone call
oh my god that's just tuesday yeah it is
just tuesday
and the 27th came around and she was a
lawyer i got your mom's birthday yo
hey everyone's got alzheimer's that's
alzheimer's brothers
that's alzheimer's dog
[ __ ] gets forgotten sometimes it's not
like i was wishing happy birthday to
someone else in her [ __ ] presence
son i got locked under a staircase
while they sung happy birthday harry
potter
yeah letters flying in i didn't have a
staircase in my apartment in new york
but still i've really colored up the
story yeah
so let me ask you this though what
where's katrina now
oh no i hope corona took her lungs
[Laughter]
so she can't blow out her own candles
yeah that's the last deep breath you
took [ __ ]
yeah katrina's looking at you now
jealous yeah she probably
is bro so all i got to say is you know
you got to understand the frustration
that these people go through
yeah all right alec baldwin
how difficult it is
i defend these guys
we're editing and we're editing them
yo you one you want to know who author's
little biggest i'll tell you what those
little pig is
go ahead mom would forget somebody's
birthday
yeah we gotta heal andrew right now i
need to get healed i think we gotta call
my
the guy that was in romney no hersey ali
or some [ __ ]
is she like african ethiopian chick or
something yo
you don't say yeah you know but uh yeah
she and she was just on
rogan well she don't hate muslims she's
like a activist or some [ __ ] mark what
you eating bro i'm about to give you a
happy birthday cupcake
oh no those are those old ones that are
full of like
that [ __ ] yeah
[Applause]
happy birthday to you
just andrew know
thank you yo i'll be honest with you
guys thank you man
now that [ __ ] felt good make a wish you
thoughtless little pig